dans les prochaines années c'est quoi
les vos prévisions de hausse de tarifs
pour les gens cette première question
que jaune portant sur une question
importante
notre souhait que l'engagement j'ai pris
quand je suis rentré en poste c'est de
s'assurer qu'on allait suivre
avoir des croissance raisonnable des
augmentations de tarifs raisonnables aux
alentours de l'inflation alors ça c'est
important et l'électricité faut gratter
historiquement on a réussi à faire ça si
vous retournez en 1963 et vous prenez
100 $ d'électricité
aujourd'hui ce sens de l'oeuvre à peu
près 7 5 le suivi parfaitement
l'inflation le gaz naturel est à 1500 et
le mazout le pétrole est à 2005
alors on ne réussit à suivre l'inflation
normal